James grows who among his many
achievements is along with me and the
son of professor
woman a member of the Yale class of 1987
himself somebody who brings together the
humanities and the sciences at Yale he
was an undergraduate major in philosophy
and psychology went on to Stanford where
he is now a professor in the psychology
department there and has done some of
the most important work in framing how
it is that we should understand emotion
regulation I had the great pleasure of
meeting James and Angela about five
years ago at a conference that I
co-organized with Hedy Cobert a
professor here at the Medical School and
in those five years have had the chance
to learn from their work and it seemed
to me when I was given the opportunity
to conduct the Shulman seminar that
there was no greater way to repay
professor Shulman for his inspiration
than to bring speakers like James and
Angela before us as a year to talk about
their work so great welcome to enter
their head James thank you
Thank You Tamar for that wonderful
introduction and thank you to both you
and Paul for selecting Angela and me as
part of your speaker series it's an
honor to be here and a pleasure to speak
with you tonight
our focus as our title suggests tonight
will be self control and I'd like to
begin just getting a pulse of the nation
by asking how many of you have ever
experienced a temptation that led you to
need to exercise self-control is there
anyone who had admit to this Marsha not
but okay yes slowly after at the end
with prompting yes thank you
good so welcome to the human condition a
fundamental part I think of being human
is navigating the temptations that we
experience now like again by way of
introduction and getting a sense of you
to think not just that the struggles you
may have had but think of loved ones
other people on your family friends what
are the kinds of things that have led
you or another person to want to
exercise self-control what are the
contexts in which you've tried to engage
or someone else's try to engage
self-control whoa what comes to mind
anybody food what else exercise anything
else
drink food drink exercise work what else
anger great so this is just a small
sampling and if I gave you another
minute or two you would I'm sure say
more but these are the things that we're
interested in in thinking together about
self-control and the definition that
we'll be using tonight that I think
integrates across the instances that
you've just called to mind is this one
self-control from our point of view for
tonight at least can be defined as the
self initiated regulation of conflicting
impulses in the service of enduringly
valued goals I'm going to try to unpack
that a little bit for you guys thinking
about the things that you call to mind
so there are two I think key features
here that we're gonna really have us all
together
the first is it when we're talking about
self-control we're talking about self
initiated action as opposed to initiated
action that's initiated by a loved or
new prompt to you a parent who you know
pushes you whoever it is this is this
falls outside our focus tonight so self
initiated action the second thing that
would like to key in on is this
asymmetric conflict so when we're
thinking about self-control tonight
we'll be thinking about a context in
which a less valued goal temptation is
more rewarding in the moment but there's
another thing that's lurking on the
mental horizon something that's more a
more valued goal that's going to be more
rewarding in the long term okay so
that's what we mean when we try to
address the kinds of things that you've
brought to our attention by way of your
examples so self-control and we I think
are going to be aiming this talk in a
fairly general way with apologies to
people who are probably more expert than
we are in this area and but at times I
think we'll jump into some of the
details with apologies to those of you
who don't care about the details so
we'll try to get that balance right I
want to say just again by way of
introduction that the way I came to this
is tomorrow intimated is via an interest
in what might be thought of as a special
case of self-control special context in
which as one example would have us think
we're trying to manage not hunger not
drinking not exercise but emotions and
so my research program is actually very
focused on this special instance of
self-control in which we are motivated
we're not always motivated but in
instances we are motivated to manage or
modify the emotions that we have
negative or positive trying to increase
or decrease those emotions in service of
some longer-term goal and my motivation
in focusing in this type of self-control
is in part driven by my training as a
clinical psychologist so I'm very
interested in normal variation
and then the extremes where people get
into so much difficulty with emotions
like sadness or anxiety that they
actually have clinical conditions that
interfere with their ability to love and
to work so that's my point of entry in
this talk we're trying something that
we've never really done before and we'll
see how it goes we're gonna trade off
occasionally and so we're literally
gonna trade off throw me this yeah thank
you so much yeah I feel like I'm like
one of those potato sack races where
it's very hard to actually be in the
same sack and I will say that nice is
your sack partner nice as my sack
partner is and in fact I should just
reiterate thanks to tomorrow and Heddy
because we met here at Yale were not for
the self regulation conference held here
I think it was November 2011 we wouldn't
be here today so um so how did I get
into this I was trying to save the
American education system one math
student at a time I was a middle school
math teacher I worked in the New York
City Public Schools the San Francisco
Public Schools and then finally the
Philadelphia public schools and after
struggling to teach kids who are going
through puberty and frankly a lot of
other things that are very hard how to
you know get X all by itself it dawned
on me actually it dawned on me probably
day three of teaching that one of the
major determinants of whether these kids
were gonna get algebra or in fact get
anything in the classroom and get on in
life with any success that one of the
crucial determinants of that would not
be their intellectual capacity or their
abstract reasoning but in fact self
control I don't know that I had the
words I certainly didn't have a very
long and wordy definition with two
crucial features but I had a very strong
intuition that the kids who are sitting
in front of me very often in fact were
giving in to temptation and in fact it
was a rational choice in the sense that
it made them feel good but the problem
was this myopic time horizon that you
know soon enough sometimes just ten
minutes later they would regret what
they had done or what they had failed to
do and that was getting them into
trouble not only in my math class but I
could tell from you know what I could
see the rest of their middle-school
lives and I
had the sense that this would get them
into trouble long after I would know
them long after they had left my middle
school classroom so I came to psychology
with a particular interest a very kind
of applied pragmatic interest in
self-control so we're gonna hand off
mics and you're gonna let me know when
you need this back the arc of the talk
is as follows we'd like to do five
things first a brief history of very
brief history and intellectual history
of the notion of self-control both from
the philosophical lens and then also
psychology secondly and here I'm gonna
pass the clicker back to James our
emerging theoretical framework for how
to put together everything that we know
about self-control in particular the
many creative ways in which we do battle
with our temptation in order to adhere
to our longer-term values the third
we're gonna talk about some emerging
research findings since we only met
recently there isn't much to talk about
but we like to tell you what we're
finding particularly in a study of
school-age children and a second study
in college students and then finally end
with take-home points and then just a
couple of teasers puzzles and open
questions to see the conversation
towards the end of the hour so without
further ado a very brief history of
self-control can be started at least as
early as Plato's Phaedrus tomorr says
it's pronounced fee drous who knew tamar
knew and James agreed I was like okay so
I'll read you this this quote from from
features which you know gives a
metaphorical account for what it might
be like to struggle internally with two
things each of which you actually desire
in some sense but then trying to
adjudicate that conflict the horse that
is on the right so this is the image of
the charioteer and two horses the horse
that is on the right or nobler side is
upright in frame and well jointed with a
high neck and a regal nose his coat is
white his eyes are black and he is a
lover of honor with modesty and he needs
no wig and is guided by verbal commands
alone the other horse is a crooked grape
jumble of limbs with a short bull neck a
pug nose black skin
bloodshot white eyes companion to wild
boasts and indecency
he's Shaggy around the ears
deaf-as-a-post and just barely yields to
horse whip and goad combined so this is
an image of willpower exerted with great
force the charioteer presumably pulling
back on the reins of the black horse and
urging the white horse to go forward if
you fast-forward to the very beginnings
of modern psychology and ask you know
how is self-control conceptualized there
well we can look to Freud for example
who believed that the ability to control
impulses was perhaps the developmental
milestone that children would need to
pass successfully in order to navigate
all dimensions of emotional and social
life later on so to quote this because I
love the phrasing here Freud the great
writer as well as the great psychologist
the ego discovers that it is inevitable
to postpone the obtaining of pleasure to
put up with a little unpleasant in
certain sources of pleasure altogether
I don't know that unpleasant needed a
new word it might be the were done
pleasure and then finally to bring us to
a character that most of us have heard
of by now because he's been on The
Colbert Report among other places and
that is Walter Mischel who was able to
operationalize to measure that what
Freud sort of specularly and poetically
talked about this ability to delay
gratification to put up with a little
unpleasant or PSA's of pleasure
altogether but it was not Freud but in
fact Walter Mischel then a young
psychologist at Stanford who was able to
come up with an experimental paradigm
bring kids into the lab and study
whether and when and how they were able
to delay gratification and I'm going to
in the next piece show three minutes of
video from Walters own experiments with
his blessing we think things we've asked
him enough times that we think Walter
would bless this particular occasion in
which we will show his video now
classically in the famous marshmallow
task of which you've probably heard
classically in the
paradigm' four-year-old children are
given a simple choice would you like one
small pile of your favorite treat which
they've identified in an earlier portion
of the experiment would you like this
little pile for example this one
marshmallow or would you like this
larger one but you know I have to come
back into the I have to go get something
in the hallway but I'll be right back
would you want to wait for the two
marshmallows or would you rather have
the one right away that's by the way not
the test in a recent study of over a
thousand kids run by the federal
government
nearly all one-thousand said no I'll
wait for the for the two rather than
have the one right away and you know
after repeatedly confirming that that in
fact is the choice the question is how
long will the child wait not do you go
on a diet but how well do you stick to
it right so it's delaying drought it's
sustaining the delay of gratification
more than the decision to delay
gratification I'm gonna play these three
minutes of video without much narration
but while I play this video I want you
to look at the kids and see whether you
can after I finish the clip just you
know raise your hand and tell me the
sorts of tricks or strategies that kids
might be using in this paradigm in order
to successfully weight these kids by the
way are little older than age four it
turns out that most Stanford parents did
not consent for their children to be
shown ad nauseam to anonymous audiences
forever but the kids in this study which
was done in a different country anyway
here we go without further annotation
okay with you like mousepad
and it's mostly quiet so here's a little
bell where the girl can bring the
experimenter back into the room she
can't wait any longer and wants to take
one treat right away
future Enron employee
now this little grows interesting you
might tell me afterwards what she's
doing and by the way I've run this study
with eleven and twelve year old they
look exactly the same as children this
age fairly tortuous tasks to complete
now those of you with grandchildren or
children may recognize what this little
girl is doing because we don't do much
of it in our older years
can't wait anymore
and by the way to properly run this
experiment there can be no windows in
the room no books to look at no working
clock nothing that might give a sense of
the passing of time or a distraction now
this little boy might I'll just point
out to you what a curious
scientific mind here but he actually
gets up out of his chair a little bit I
just want you to notice this and moves
the Bell from where it started to the
far corner and I love ending on this one
because as an Asian female we pretty
much know what she's gonna do right
obviously delay gratification but in
fact gender and racial stereotypes do
not always hold she does not wait okay
so um so I'd love to hear volunteers you
know those of you who remember kids this
age or that in particular but really
anyone we've all been this age after all
you know what are some of the things
that these kids are doing and you just
hate raise your hand I'll try to see you
yeah yeah so the little boy kicking the
table that might have served the
function of just distracting himself
from this by the way excruciating the
boring task to do yeah anything else
distraction yeah
particularly maybe the girl who is doing
that little pretend play or self talk so
so it seems like there is both self-talk
and just pretend right like maybe taking
on a role of someone like playing the
experiment or yeah it's great yeah Oh
give it you mean the little boy who
licked it oh by the way so the little
boy who licked it and then cleverly
sandwiched the OREA I'm sure he's not
the first child in humanity to figure
out that you could lick the Oreo you
know and maybe pretend that you didn't
eat it the way you code for delay time
in this task I mean that was very clever
but the moment the child you know
ingests even just a little bit of the
kind they they're told this in advance
if you eat any of it it's kind of over
and you can only have the first small
treat the trial sort of over so we would
only count the number of seconds to that
first bite yeah but that little bit of
taste you know sort of like I'm not
gonna eat all of dessert
I just have a bite yeah that is actually
I think I self-control strategy that
many of us try to use sometimes not for
our better but yeah yeah interesting yes
so definitely the moving the Bell
farther away in some way I mean I think
it was an intentional and deliberate
move and maybe one more yeah yes and
maybe in particularly the girl who had
her back turned
so channeling my inner Walter Mischel
devil get thee behind me right so this
idea that out of sight is out of mind
and therefore we should not pay
attention to it so so absolutely I think
all of these things actually are true
about the children that we see in just
this very simple way if thinking about
what Freud really meant by the delaying
of pleasure and the forgoing of certain
pleasures altogether but I think what's
also striking to me as a as a as a
scholar who tried to get a handle on
this massive literature and really
self-control is by some metrics the
largest and the most rapidly growing
empirical literature in all of a
psychology just trying to figure out how
to understand this you know diverse
almost infinite number of things that
people could do and do do in order to
exert self-control this is where I think
I got a little bit lost and I think it
was just around them that I met tomorrow
and James and James is gonna walk you
through what we're thinking as of a
useful maybe not the only and maybe not
the corner quote right framework for
that but a really useful way of
organizing these strategies according to
their functional role and when they're
used so this is the time we're super so
this brings us to the theoretical
framework we're using and we find useful
to organize the extraordinarily complex
strategies and they're very wide range
of strategies that people use in
everyday life and the way the way that
we begin to think about this is to
observe as many others have using a
hierarchical framework or framework that
when you think about what someone is
about what each of us wants to achieve
it's useful as a first move to make a
distinction between fairly high-level
abstract
two goals that we have the top of any
given hierarchy and then the goals that
serve those higher-level goals and on
down the chain multiplying goals
typically as you go down all the way
that low-level actions things
observables actually take place in the
world let's take as an example a goal of
mine to be a good dad to my kids so
there'll be a high level goal in this
panel and then within that space I'm
thinking about how I decompose that one
of the things that I might want to do is
to be really plugged into my kids lives
so that might be a the leftmost
second-level goal I also want to be
emotionally present to my kids that's
let's say the middle second-level goal
and I want a model sort of healthy
behavior to my kids that might be the
leftmost second-level goal and each of
these in turn can be decomposed right so
if I want to be plugged into my kids
lives I might want to be plugged into
both academic or extracurricular lives
action entailment and the key idea here
is that each of these actions flows in
part from goals that are supported by
and driven in fact by higher-level goals
and so there's a nested hierarchical
structure the other thing to notice I
think in this scheme to get us started
is the idea that there are some goals
let's take this one here that are doing
joint work that are jointly supporting
let's say my goal of being emotionally
present might lead me to really
prioritize asking questions engaging
with the kids but that goal might also
serve to instantiate my wanting to model
healthy behavior so there going to be
some goals that are doing joint work and
similarly some actions they can be
serving you know each of several goals
simultaneously so far so good nothing
terribly new here Carver and Shai are
many other people in psychology and
outside of psychology have uses this
sort of framework the thing to notice
from our point of view is that not all
goals live in this kind of Tidy
structure there are some goals that as
we move through our lives look
like this more like this they're
activated in a bottom-up fashion rather
than a top-down fashion so is removing
through our lives happily we see this
gorgeous piece of cake sitting on the
side now sometimes that's not a problem
to see a gorgeous piece of cake because
it's okay for us to eat the cake and
that's not at all in tension with any of
these other goals that are important to
us let's say in a given domain sometimes
these locally active goals are actually
quite strong denoted by this dark line
and again still not necessarily a
problem if there's no tension what we're
interested in is cases of course where
this lovely piece of chocolate cake that
emerges on the side of our kitchen right
after breakfast in full view of all the
kids promotes this urge is desperate
urge to eat it in front of the kids and
that's in tension with my goal to model
healthy eating habits from my kids
okay and so there's attention and that's
the problem and that's where there's
this tension between a longer sort of
more durable good a goal that's
supported by this network of highly
valued goals there's a tension between
this on the one hand and then this
immediately active quite strong but
limited duration good that's represented
by this other goal and in circumstances
like this when we're tempted we may then
activate processes that weaken this
temporarily active goal and strengthen
the longer term valued goal with the end
product of having this one drop out of
sight on the far left the cake then
becomes less attractive and the goal of
eating as I should becomes more dominant
and what we're interested in in this
another way of putting what we're
interested in in this talk is just this
space what is it exactly that's
happening as we have these competing
goals some of which are imbued with
value because of their nesting within
this hierarchical structure the tie all
the way back to things like really care
about being a good
being a good student being a good
partner and others of which although
they have local force and they're
terribly compelling in the moment don't
derive that long-term value and so what
we would mean to actually have ourselves
do is this even though the other is more
dominant and the question that we have
now for you and for for conversation is
what are these processes exactly that
are happening in this yellow box this
domain of self control and what we have
found it useful in thinking about this
to do is to say well let's take a step
back and let's think about for any one
of these goal action units what's
exactly happening as a motive gathers
strength and one very simple way of
thinking about it is to say that well
there's a situation some features of a
situation that we attend to and then
appraise or evaluate trying to determine
their goodness or badness and that
activates a response tendency a simple
generic sort of way of thinking about
how impulses get built over time and
then if there's a response tendencies
strong enough it then activates an
action that then they act on the
situation the local world that prompted
the reason we find this combination of a
hierarchical goal framework and this
process conception of impulse generation
helpful is that it suggests points of
intervention places in which we can
intervene in this impulse generative
cycle to modify the the incipient
response either making it weaker if it's
an undesired response or making it
stronger if it's a desirable response so
this is an effort to get under the hood
and think well what are the processes
that can be activated in service in that
yellow zone when there's a conflict
between these two goals in order to
strengthen the goal that we'd like to
have stronger and weaken the goal that
would like to have weaker and the way
that we thought about this is this five
families of self control processes
that'll be drawn across this
developing impulse we're gonna start
with situation selection so this is at
the very front end making decisions
about the kinds of situations we expose
ourselves to with the view to the impact
they'll have on the impulses that get
generated that sounds very abstract but
it's not abstract Arab Lee abstract for
example selecting your physical
situation you sit and this is a very
small auditorium but if you were in a
very big auditorium it would really make
a big difference whether you're seated
in the very back where the oxygen levels
are low when you can barely see anything
happening on stage and you've got banks
and banks of computers in front of you
or you're up front and personal okay and
this will dramatically determine how
likely you are perhaps to succumb to the
temptation of going way off topic and
off task but also our social situation I
think this is another domain in which we
make and children make people at all
ages make decisions about who to expose
ourselves to folks on the Left or folks
on the right which is going to be more
conducive to the kinds of behaviors that
we want to have expressed in our lives
here's some examples when interviewed
high school kids and Angela will talking
a little bit about some of the studies
that we've done verbatim suggestions for
students from students who are trying to
study well what would you do what should
you do in order to really you know
handle the temptations that you
experience when you're studying lock
myself in a room without my phone so
that it doesn't become a distraction
that would fall into exactly the
category we're thinking about I go to
the library as being in a quiet and
controlled environment would make me
focus I don't think they have what used
to be called weenie bins here in cross
campus library anymore this is a
artifact of hundreds of years ago
probably but I will vouch for the fact
that what do they call they probably
call something totally different
oh is that right okay
no this okay sorry this dates me and us
doesn't it
all right but that was a very secure way
of fending off my roommates desperate
attempts to have me go have pizza
instead of studying when I was here all
right so let's take the second family of
self control strategies situation
modification here it's not that you're
making decisions about which situation
to expose yourself to it's you're in the
situation but you can fiddle with the
situation in various important ways as
we saw for example with the kid putting
the bail further away I think that would
be an example here one exists one case
that comes up again and again and we
struggle with this I teach psychology
one one of my favorite classes to teach
we have that's uncommon and I see these
laptops all over the place
and I struggle every year to figure out
what's the best way this wouldn't be
self control if I did it but what I
really like that happen is the students
make good decisions about how to use
their laptops and here we have you know
I hope this isn't typical certainly of
Stanford or Yale for that matter you
know this vast array of distractions
which can be silenced of course by
modifying situation as appropriate
shutting it shoving that laptop
we know empirically that having cookies
close by in a glass jar just means
you're gonna eat a lot more those
cookies even if you don't want to then
if the jar is not see-through or and or
it's further away these are gonna be
examples of situation modification
here's what the high school students say
I would shut out my phone and put it
under my pillow so it wouldn't be
tempted by to touch it remove all
distractions and tell one of my parents
I had a big exam so they're check-in on
the enemy force stay on task very
interesting mix of self and sort of
inducing others so self based self
initiated induction of other support
attention deployments the third family
of self control strategies and you can
see we're just moving systematically
down this an impulse generative line so
we're imagining as many of the kids
exemplified that if you gave attention
this is gonna be a terrifically power
powerful entry point and this is why
the Kipp program has it's one of its
centerpieces the rule that you pay
attention pay attention eyes on the
teacher a terrifically important way of
helping kids stay with the program here
are some examples from high school
students ease off texting by ignoring my
phone remind myself that even the most
boring classes count towards my GPA
which will affect my future and in the
discussion we can come to some of these
cases as in the second of these that are
interesting blends potentially of some
of the categories I'm trying to
artificially segment out for you but for
now we're focusing on the attentional
dimension fourth family of regulatory
processes cognitive change
now we're attending to potentially
tempting situation but we're trying to
change the way we're thinking about it
we're using these filters as it were
rows called glasses to transform by
cognitively representing the incoming
information in a way that biases the
action tendencies in favor of the
desirable action path and away from the
tempting action path examples I would
tell myself that if I study for an hour
I can reward myself by playing video
games later setting goals breaking the
project up into pieces would have that
we in part some contact with this
cognitive change family of self-control
lastly response modulation we saw I
think some of that where you just grit
your teeth and crush mind with mine
you just try really hard okay so this is
and some examples from our kids in the
high school study just deal with it and
study just do it
I've worked so hard this year for my
grades I don't watch TV anymore it's no
longer a temptation for me I just focus
and get my work done alright so what
we're going to do now with that is a
framework so this hierarchical goal
conception that highlights the
difference between the two types of
goals that our intention and the idea
that somehow we are engaging processes
admit modify the relative strength of
these two goals and then a word about
how we're thinking about the unfolding
of the impulse generative process and
the ways you can
intervene and Angelus now going to talk
a little bit about some of the
implications that flow from this
temporal segmentation of strategies and
a little bit of about some studies we've
done to test those yeah great thank you
very much okay terrific so so I think
you have a picture of really two
theoretical models we figured two
speakers will just squeeze in to
theoretical mouths the first a
hierarchical way of understanding what
does it mean to have a goal that we
would call desirable well a goal that's
embedded in a structure where really the
top of that pyramid is something which
is of enduring and personal significance
versus these you know chocolate cake
kind of goals that come and go and
aren't really anchored in that way and
the second is this process model how do
impulses come about and given the
information about how they come about
where can we selectively strategically
intervene so you know what are the
predictions from such of a you know
theoretical approach the first one is
that impulses in this model are posited
to grow or in fact diminish but
nevertheless change over time in terms
of their strengths and we can capitalize
that if you think about snowballs
running down mountains if you want to
stop a snowball try to stop it at the
top don't try to stop it at the bottom
so if there is an impulse to eat the
chocolate cake instead of modeling good
healthy behavior to your teenage son and
daughter then better to nip that impulse
in the bud as it were as opposed to let
that impulse flourish and grow and then
at the very last stage for example in
response modulations simply just stop
yourself from eating it secondly the
idea that this earlier intervention well
I went to that one so let me let me move
on to then the third one the idea that
temptation oriented impulses in our
model would have a head start is crucial
the metaphor of snowballs rolling down
mountains doesn't necessarily get to you
to the idea that you should go earlier
except for very importantly the snowball
that is the chocolate cake eating
snowball does at a very early start on
us and in fact we would argue that there
are certain automatic
means by which these impulses do augment
self augment over time whereas our
desirable tendencies that are embedded
in this pyramidal structure may need
more help actually in in growing and
strength and so if you put this together
the idea is that earlier is better and
what's earlier in our model the
situational strategies so if you asked
me you know if a fifth grade teacher
wants to help her fifth grade students
get more self-controlled
should she tell them to you know use
more willpower the last stage I would
say well that's not a very good idea but
that's what most fifth grade teachers do
right just control yourself for God's
sake is the phrase that comes out of a
lot of our mouths and we have nothing
else to say I wouldn't actually even put
much stock in the kind of later
cognitive strategies of cognitive change
and attentional deployment because there
again you know the impulses have already
grown in strength if they're a bit and
just to turn your attention away from
the chocolate cake once you've sort of
you know put yourself close to it etc
that may not be the smartest thing what
may be the smartest thing to do is
actually to choose or change your
situation when impulses to do bad things
that are enjoyable in a moment are still
nascent and I want to move to experiment
that James and I have run recently with
high school students and actually my lab
manager Alyssa's in the audience she was
the person really running it James and I
were just standing around on the
sidelines waving our hands the idea is
quite simple there were three conditions
in this experiment high school students
were in one of three conditions in the
first condition they were taught
situation modification strategies we
didn't put them through the pain and
suffering of the process model but we
simply showed them certain you know key
empirical findings like for example the
study at Cornell that found indeed when
secretaries were given candy in clear
glass stars that were within hands reach
they ate dramatically more then
secretaries randomly assigned to the
same candy but now in jars that were
opaque and which because they were 6
feet away required getting out of your
seat to actually
take one right so they were given a
little tour of findings suggesting to
them that self control depends a lot on
your situation and therefore you can
change your situation in order to exert
self-control
so that was one condition the condition
that we expected to do quote unquote the
best the second condition was a response
modulation condition that simply
exhorted these high school students to
use willpower you know we gave them some
YouTube video of TED Talks and talking
about the importance of self-control and
just suppressing impulses when you
needed to so we called that the
willpower condition or the response
modulation condition and we expected
that potentially to have some effect as
lecturers sometimes do at least in the
short run but not to be as efficacious
as the first condition and a third
condition was simply a no treatment
control so it's a three arm study one
week follow-up we asked the same
students to report on academic goals
that they had set during that first
session and in the preliminaries
findings that I'm gonna show you simply
quantified how much these students said
that they did in fact accomplish the
goals that they had set a week earlier
so we equipped these students with three
you know with the no treatment has
nothing I guess and then there's
response modulation and situation
modification on the vertical axis we
have self-reported goal accomplishment
that one week later and there is a
significant difference favoring oh the
page at meet with philosophers James
push the wrong button there you go yeah
there we go
fairly straightforward actually in a
replication study with college students
we replicated the study design exactly
and then you have nearly identical
results in the college sample we also
asked it it's at one week follow-up over
the previous week how tempting did it
feel to actually resist distractions and
things that would hinder you in
attaining your academic goal and in fact
we find partial mediations so we find
that those students assigned randomly to
the situation modification condition
were able to well I don't know if
there's a able to experienced fewer
feelings or less strong feelings of
temptation
that partially at least explained the
effective situation modification on goal
attainment so I want to say that this is
preliminary work James and I just came
from Dean Carlin's office in the
Economics Department where we were
talking about replicability and how it's
very very important not to cherry-pick
your results and you know so we need
larger samples we need independent
confirmation that in fact situation
modification does work but if it does I
think the questions are really
intriguing about you know where this
research takes us the take home from
this lecture for me and I would just say
that you know for the last three years
of collaborating with tomorrow and James
is that our intuitions about self
control may be in fact completely the
opposite of what science is now telling
us may be a most effective when you ask
fifth graders ninth graders or even 47
year olds like what is self control and
you know how should you do it you know
you often get these kind of Nike slogan
like well just do it or Nancy Reagan
just don't do it like you know that and
I think that we're just by the way is a
giveaway that people are not thinking
about artful creative ways and in fact
ways that would take the effort out of
effortful self control altogether so we
have this intuition that self control is
a mental act that is something that is
you know akin to a charioteer trying to
control too difficult or one difficult
horse the other one you know something
that is about strife and struggle and in
fact these kind of very clever things
put the Bell a little farther away turn
the cell phone off don't buy chocolate
chip cookies in the first place these
clever little tricks may not be
recognizable as self-control but in fact
they are James and I were not able to
identify many journal articles on this
topic but we found an unlimited number
of better house and gardens you know fit
day.com better use Self magazine essays
about these tricks to for example
exercise more or to eat less so there
are some puzzles and open questions and
just to seed the conversation now I
didn't talk about grit nobody ever
asked me to talk about self-control so
we capitalized on this invitation to
actually talk about self-control and not
grit I actually love talking about grit
but I'll just say that you know James
and I have actually thought long and
hard about how grit is and isn't like
self-control we'd be delighted to
entertain that question as a group to
what extent are situational strategies
in fact indirectly intrapsychic
strategies so you could say the first
two strategies in the model are about
changing the world around you and the
last three are about changing things
inside your head but if you turn off
your cell phone so that you don't look
at it so that it doesn't deter you from
doing your work isn't the turning it off
in fact indirectly intrapsychic because
its operating via attention deployment
so that's emerging thinking but but
something that we're eager to pursue
third to what extent can a desirable
impulse itself become automatic now in
one of the quotes that we showed you
from a high school student who said you
know just you know just get on with my
work and so forth I've worked really
hard this year so now and there's the
implication so now I can just get to my
work and there's the implication that a
habit has been formed and we're really
interested in the intersection of habit
and automated desirable response and and
self-control as we've discussed it today
we've made the claim that earlier is
better in the context of the process
model that works if you're in a cycle of
situation flowing to attention flowing
to you know cognitive representation to
a response but of course there's the
question of you know what if you are not
within a given cycle but for example
using cognitive change at a much earlier
cycle so the process model is an
iterative one but if you are in an
earlier iteration but at a later stage
in this cycle you know is that actually
can that actually be better than a you
know later cycle but an earlier stage so
I hope that wasn't complete jargon my
point is that you know the idea that you
flowing from situation all the way to
response modulation sort of leaves out
the important detail that it's a
recursive so then you have like go back
to you've modified the situation now
what situation am I in and the idea that
an earlier cycle altogether may trump
any kind of like with in cycle ordering
effects that that we've talked about
today and then finally who or what there
is the ultimate responsibility of making
these situational tweaks that optimize
self-control should you be the one to go
into Starbucks and say no can I have the
children side I don't even know if they
have a small-size at Starbucks I don't
think they do like is does it behoove
you as an individual to do that or
should there be a tax on extra-large
lattes with whipped cream and caramel
right so is it society is it the
government should Pepsi Cola take for
some responsibilities here and here's
where for example our talk on
self-control intersects with the working
behavioral economics in particular you
know the work of scientists who call
this general idea like nudging the
consumer towards more desirable
behaviors and away from less desirable
ones so we're very interested in you
know all these questions and challenges
I think the thing to do now is to say
thank you very much for your attention
and let's open it up for a bit of Q&A
however long Paul and tomorrow say
without any offense to the speakers yes
right yeah yeah
great so let's give people a second to
leave if they need to and then we'll
start with question and then there's a
question about look I could see a hand
go up yeah motion those in order no it's
really good yeah thank you for coming
please
great
okay now the funny part become so there
were a lot of questions I know right
which one do you want to do the develop
do you want to do that why study kids
yeah and I think you said that you've
heard that self-control stops developing
at what age I didn't catch that
but 21 plus 5 Oh 21 plus 5 okay I didn't
catch that okay and so so adolescence is
a particularly interesting phase of life
in which to study self-control in part
because not everyone but many
psychologists believe two things are
actually happening in adolescence we
have this gradually increasing
competence this gradually increasing
capacity to for example modulate
responses like in the last stage of the
process model just you know using the
front part of the brain right to do that
or potentially through increasing
sophistication with strategies that
we've talked about right but
nevertheless as you get older getting
better at that part of the you know the
equation but in adolescents there's this
spike in the strength the intensity of
risk of impulses themselves so you might
be gradually from childhood through
adolescence into early adulthood and
even middle adulthood get gradually more
sophisticated and better at regulating
impulses but you have to also account
for the spike in the strength of the
impulses and it's been called the
perfect storm that in adolescents you
have still emerging still developing
control in combination with terribly
powerful impulses to do risky things try
things that are exciting even if they're
dangerous break rules etc and because of
that adolescents actually get into more
trouble either than young adults adults
or get into more trouble than kids who
are like 10 right which you have to sort
of explain this kind of peak that
happens right there so adolescence is
interesting I don't know that there is
actually strong evidence that you know
you're set like plaster by the time
you're 30 years old which you know it
was one idea that
veiled in psychology for a long time I
think the consensus is that there may be
differing levels of plasticity and
change throughout the life course but
there always is plasticity and change
throughout the life course so it's good
to show up at a lecture like this even
if you're past the age of you know 21
plus 5 or whatever the figure was so
that's the adolescence piece of it do
you want to handle the non-conscious
processes and self control or the
ecological validity question sure good
these are great questions
yeah really let's just sort of thing
together so with Angela I think I would
say that on the first of the two
questions we can learn a lot I think by
studying even immature you know
organisms because we're interested in
the processes that will support not only
their functioning but also subsequent
functioning and there are a number of
strategies of psychologists and other
scientists have of course as you know
very well in looking at organisms as
they develop to see what order
capacities come online what the stress
points are but then also as organisms
mature what contexts are there that
actually suppress optimal performance
versus enhance optimal performance so I
think for me that's a recipe for looking
at the full range of functioning from
immature organisms all the way through
actually late late adulthood there's
very interesting evidence to my mind in
the domain park about self-control in
general one special case is emotion
control and in that special domain
there's actually I think very compelling
evidence that even it's a very late and
adulthood people are getting in some
ways better and better at regulating
their emotions and so this is well
beyond twenty one plus five this is into
one 60s and 70s and Beyond sometimes
greater use of some of these more
sophisticated strategies even as the
machinery that's enabling this some of
these prefrontal circuits are being
degraded with age so that that's it I
think call for being interested in
really the full range of variation both
age certainly culture which we've not am
sighs but also intactness of functioning
I think all of this is telling us
something about the underlying processes
with respect to the second of the two
questions as I understood it a number of
interesting parts to that I think we've
tried to express at a very you know
first level approximation sort of a
framework that we're thinking is useful
in sorting out the chaos of this field
so if you look in either the full field
of self control in psychology and
humanities more generally or if you look
in emotion regulation as a subfield it's
just chaotic it has been chaotic and so
what we're trying to do is I think offer
a very simple framework for beginning to
think about processes and how they can
be integrated we're not making the claim
and I apologize if it sounded as though
we're making the claim but this is
necessarily how people themselves think
about what they're doing right so we
want to distinguish between the kinds of
entry points that might be available
given what we think are the in this case
psychological steps that go into impulse
generation we're also I think I'm
certainly very interested in my lab in
understanding the neurobiological basis
of these different steps than a lot of
work on cognitive change in particular
what are the systems that enable that
form of regulation so I think we we're
interested in the processes and
organizing points of intervention but
make no claims that this isn't very
straightforward as a way of thinking
about this in naive psychology I think
it does make some contact with naive
psychology but I want I think that's a
for me that's a separate case I and I
and I'm not sure that I would want to
rely entirely on someone's
introspections about sort of what works
best for just the reasons Angela said
you know we have plenty of people saying
just do it or just don't do it or you
know a lot of confusion about the many
things that might work and what we're
trying to do is to apply the scientific
method to these age-old problems plato
of course wasn't himself the first in
the Western tradition and in each of the
world traditions this has been a
centerpiece of discussion so that's the
first approximation to your two
questions you had a question a moment
ago was that
irrelevant by the other discussion yeah
I mean I think the idea that there are
these social forces that are usually
thought of as forces beyond your control
right your roommate comes home and says
we're all going to I guess used to be
Naples whenever they go out to now and
you know you didn't want that to happen
you couldn't predict that that would
happened but then it happened right so
so there's that element of social forces
but I think there's also at least some
wiggle room right for you to proactively
direct social forces in the way that you
want it to be directed so for example
there was this little picture of you
know kids drinking on a brick wall and
then like studious kids I don't know
like playing violin or getting ready for
like SAT prep or something like that and
I'm you know the inspiration for that
actually is I did a focus group with
tenth and fifth graders in the Bronx New
York very low-income area and a very
wizened ten-year-old was saying it sorry
a tenth grader was saying to a fifth
grader from the same school population
you know if I only knew at your age what
I have learned now at the age of like 16
I would have gotten into a different
crowd because once you you know hang out
with certain kids start to do what they
do and was really hard for me to you
know actually pull myself out of it so I
think to some extent there were degrees
of freedom or for that not easy right
but there's some way that you can try to
manipulate your social circumstances to
advantage you know whether that be you
know telling your roommates like stop
doing that I'm trying you know like or
finding different kinds of friends to
hang out with so not an easy question
but I think that assuming that social
forces are outside of the bounds of self
control actually might be the an
incomplete way of thinking about it yes
so you were wondering about whether
desire to become automated and so the
way I was thinking about that was that
when when people have certain habits we
tend to give them a label a trade for
for that characteristic the label of
principles would coherent concept
because if it is then it might that it
might attach to certain people who
across different domains have something
also is there is there any psychological
study about about principal people and
what the principal correlates to that's
interesting okay I'll go that yeah okay
so yeah all right plug current as it
okay so super interesting question say
that I had a graduate student named Eli
who came to me and very soon in his
research with me became really
interested in the extent to which like
Tiger Woods or certain politicians the
list goes on and on there was a
demonstration of extraordinary
self-control across a wide range of life
domains and yet in one a certain failing
right so you know these tend to make
headlines you're like really like and in
particular because you know for example
Sports Illustrated ran an entire feature
story on Tiger Woods not very long
before he got into a lot of trouble
about how he was a paragon of
self-discipline across every domain in
his life from finance to you know what
are you putting his mouth when he woke
up in the morning and etc so um so I
think first of all I should just
acknowledge that human beings are as
Michel de Montaigne said in his essays
in the 16th century we are more unlike
ourselves than we are unlike other
people in other words there can be
tremendous variation in the extent to
which we are you know self controlled in
one domain and impulsive in another now
you wanted to point out that maybe some
people actually were fairly self
controlled across domain no vices and
and I do think there is the you know
certainly that that could be true and
certainly I mean I know a little bit
about this there are research areas
where they will document that for
example it's not only
true that some people are more
emotionally regulated than others but
some people are just more consistent
across their domains of their life right
so consistently dysregulated or
consistently regulated and I think you
can put a name to it you can call it
principled or actually in the
psychoanalytic tradition I think this
used to be called what someone was
integrated and integrated personality
was someone who had a coherence across
the many domains of their life so yes
there is domain specificity but not all
of us are at quite as a regular in our
profiles as people like Tiger Woods and
maybe those of us who have more
consistency in a desireable way we could
call principled and maybe I guess you
could say that you know that starts to
then border on my notion of grit which
is that you have a superordinate goal
that really organizes everything else in
your life and then there's tremendous
consistency in that everything that you
do in your waking and sometimes your
sleeping hours is goal congruent to that
higher-order goal one challenge I just
just in terms of the connotative range
when you talk about principles that sort
of sounds good but I don't think there's
anything in what Angela just said that
says that these super ordinate goals are
goals that others would endorse right so
you
I mean let's not speculate but I mean
you or others might have just these
really toxic goals that you're very very
disciplined about and right and that
we're not I mean to say that they're I
mean yes there's a sense in which you
can say you're a principled person to
aspire to killing everybody in sight but
there's this sort of oddness to that so
I mean I I do think but I very much
endorse what Angela said so we are just
at the time you said we turning up the
pumpkins should we stop at this point